das war so eine die hat gesagt ich gehe
nun mal kurz kopieren und dann war die
20 minuten weg und kamen wieder mit so
einem fetten brötchen und heute ist
wirklich wieder einiges lustiges dabei
wir haben unter anderem das schlechteste
zeugnis was mir jemals zugeschickt wurde
letzte woche hat mir das beste diese
woche das schlechteste hey was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video jahr leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut heute mal wieder die
location wo auch glaube ich mein bis
jetzt beliebtestes video gedreht wurde
also das war glaube ich das zweite
zeugnis video von mir vor ungefähr einem
halben jahr oder so und ja vor navarro
kam mir neuartig habe gesagt ey gerade
gibt's wieder zeugnisse die sommerferien
stehen die einen haben sie schon die
andern ich keine ahnung wo bei instagram
ist voll mit irgendwelchen zeugnissen
also schickt mir da wirklich viele zu
ich habe gestern wieder eine stunde
damit verbracht passende zu finden aber
schaut auf jeden fall alex wie auf
instagram vorbei und schickt mir gerne
euer zeugnis dazu wenn ihr auch mal bock
hab im video zu sein ich habe letzte
woche gesagt diese passiert jetzt immer
freitags um 14 uhr geben solange wie ich
bock drauf habt dann will ich gar nicht
lange lagern wir fangen an mit folge 2
staffel 2 netflix und so das gerne einen
daumen nach oben dafür noch ein paar ich
würd mal sagen weil 8000 gleich es gibt
es nächsten freitag den nächsten paar
und heute ist wirklich wieder einiges
lustiges dabei wir haben unter anderem
das schlechteste zeugnis was mir jemals
zugeschickt wurde letzte woche hat mir
das beste diese woche das schlechteste
und ich würde sagen wir fangen wir an
mit dem zeugnis von elli erl er hat mir
geschrieben herr alex ist mein zeugnis
von diesem halbjahr
ich bin auf einer gesamtschule bin aber
in einer gymnasialklasse in meiner
klasse sind dieses jahr richtig viele
sitzen geblieben oder sondern eine real
klasse gegangen und elli hatten schnitt
von 10 also alles einzeln und unten
steht dann deswegen habe ich auch mit
reingenommen die noten in den fächern
und lernen bereichen sind soweit keine
kurs zugehörigkeit angegeben ist auf die
anforderungen des bildungsganges des
gymnasiums gezogen
dieses zeugnis ist dem
hauptschulabschluss gleichgestellt jetzt
wird es irgendwie ganz schön herren ich
kenne mich jetzt mit dem schulsystem
auch nicht so gut aus aber wenn da steht
dass es auf gymnasium niveau ist und
dann im hauptschulabschluss
gleichgestellt ist natürlich sein weil
sie in der neuen klasse ist dass sie
jetzt praktisch im hauptschulabschluss
hat oder so kennt man die kommentare an
sonst nur 10 watt will man sagen was so
gut wie ich damals und wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten und zwar eigentlich
sehr interessant ich lasse euch erst mal
den text verdienen sie mir dazu
privat oder er nenne sie erweiterten
realschulabschluss mit 30 fehltagen
macht das meiner sport war ich nie da
war es mir zu blöd ist weil man nur
gemacht wird und das soll jetzt haben
wir hier 30 fehltage ich weiß nicht
jedes halbjahr hat ich würde mal
schätzen irgendwas zwischen 120 und 140
tage also ein viertel war sich schon mal
nicht da deutsch 2 englisch drei
geschichte drei bla bla bla und religion
nicht erteilt musik nicht erteilt ob ich
durch sport 1 4 obwohl sie nie dabei ist
ja alles cool also wir haben jetzt am
mittleren dreier schritt jetzt muss man
dazu sagen ich kriege so nachricht nur
leute schreiben ja ich war zwar oft
nicht da leute ärgern mich und so
deswegen ist mein zeugnis auch nicht so
gut und das ist eigentlich auch der
grund warum ich das zeug ist jetzt mit
reingenommen habe ich meine ich kenne es
auch selber aus meiner eigenen schule
waren dass man natürlich immer leute mit
dabei hat einen sport dies nicht so gut
können und vor allem wenn man dann auch
in der fünften sechsten siebten achten
klasse ist gibt es dort auch viele die
sich darüber lustig machen und dann erst
ab der zehnten klasse oder so merkt man
dass es eigentlich total dumm ist weil
ich war ein gut ist doch scheißegal ob
eine person jetzt gut sport kann oder
nicht ich finde man sollte einfach sein
eigenes ding machen also wird er ein
einzelsport hat und dabei habe die
absolut unsportlich sind dann lasst sie
doch macht dann haben die halten oder
drei dafür haben die dann halt in marina
1404 also der eine können das gut und
der andere das sollte jemand nur kurz
sagen also schöne grüße an dich lass
dich nicht unterkriegen und nächstes
jahr wird ein zeugnis gut kommen wir zu
meinen absoluten favoriten und es warten
wir auch der liebe weiter die heister
ich weiß den namen leider nicht mehr auf
jeden fall geht ja auch eine waldorf
schulen das sind ja diese schulen da
kriegt man keine noten da kriegt man zu
jedem fach sein text geschickt die haben
da auch total andere fächer eigentlich
gewohnt sind wie zum beispiel das fach
tanzen oder auch das fach gemüse abbau
durch verwechselt das fach heißt
gartenbau und dieser text als ich ihn
zum ersten mal gelesen habt ich hoffe
ich wirklich tot gelacht das ist
natürlich jetzt überhaupt kein angriff
gegen überweidung schülern finde ich
auch cool dass man auf einer
waldorfschule ist meine etwas komplett
anderes aber ich musste einfach ein
bisschen grinsen und zwar so dass
verreist garten brauchen die schüler der
achten klasse verbracht und das letzte
halbe jahr des gartenbau unterrichts mit
allen
herbst anfallenden arbeiten gemüsegarten
kummer von der schule nach hause eltern
fragen und was habt ihr heute so gemacht
ja wir waren den ganzen tag im
gemüsegarten sie ernteten das selbst
angebaute pflegten und jedes wo es nötig
war räumten beta ab um winter
zwischenfrucht einzusehen harkten laub
und sitzen komposter auf man schließlich
gab es noch winterlich erarbeiten wie
das bitten der adventskränze und das
kerzenziehen geht noch weiter nur was
ich sagen wollte
viele regen sich darüber auf dass man zb
jetzt im deutschen schulsystem überhaupt
nichts darüber lernen wie funktionieren
eigentlich steuern wie schließlich meine
versicherung ab und so weiter und hier
musste ich jetzt auch ganz ehrlich sagen
für mich macht es überhaupt keinen sinn
wieso man als waldorfschüler einfach hat
wo man im garten arbeitet ich meine wenn
man gärtner werden möchte dann kann man
das ja natürlich machen indem man nach
der schule eine ausbildung zum gärtner
macht aber ich glaube so höchstens 0,3
prozent der jugendlichen wollen gärtner
werden und dann gibt es einfach einfach
das heißt gartenbau und die schüler die
hier auf die weiter schule gehen sollen
im garten arbeiten als schulfach und
werden dafür benotet das ist für mich
noch dümmer als im deutschunterricht so
eine stinkt langweiliges buch zu lesen
was man nur liest weil es halt von der
schule so vorgegeben wird und man aber
nie im leben wieder brauchen wir
trotzdem sehr lustig es geht noch weiter
der person gelang es während des letzten
halbes jahres im schulgarten nicht seine
unverhohlene unlust abzulegen und selbst
verantwortung zu übernehmen am ehesten
ließ er sich vom tätig sein damit
schüler anregen und mit dem also das
geht ja wirklich überhaupt nicht man man
man gibt es ja gar nicht alle arbeiten
richtig fleißig im garten mit ersten
schönen dingen gemüsegarten und was
machst du du sitzt einfach daneben und
lässt er das obst verwelken so wir
machen weiter mit jennys zeugnis jenny
hat auch wirklich ein richtig geiles
zeugt ist ja wir haben hier viele fächer
an den jenny teilgenommen hat jenny hat
31 versäumte stunden und sie hat aber
auch nur drei fächer und da frage ich
mich wenn man schon nur drei fächer hat
wie kann man denn dann 31 versäumte
stunden haben ich meine dann war es ja
fast so gut wie nie da ich habe am
anfang gedacht hat einfach für die
anderen fischer keine noten
kommen weil sie anscheinend nicht da war
aber das ist ja gar nicht möglich mit
nur 31 versorgung stunden das sind
ungefähr eine woche weil sie nicht da
und wieso sie jetzt nur drei fächer hat
ich meine das ist ja sogar ein gymnasium
achte klasse kann ich nicht verstehen
ich gerne in den kommentaren darüber
auch trotzdem jenny natürlich auch
schöne grüße an dich und drei fächer nur
zu haben
entspannung kommen wir zu einem nächsten
interessanten zeugnis und zwar aus
tschechien als ich das gelesen habe
dachte ich mir okay um schritt gymnasium
sie hat für mich das ganze ein bisschen
übersetzt das heißt wir haben hier
giovanni heizverhalten czeschka
tschechisch anblick jackie hide englisch
nämlich kitschig deutsch und in
tschechien gibt es anscheinend nur eine
note die heißt wie bonnie nicht wahr sie
hat mir dazu geschrieben
politik heißt halbjahr von wie bonnie
heißt sehr gut also 1 in tschechien gibt
es nur fünf noten von 1 bis 5 aber sie
hat einfach alles eins ja auch
interessant entweder du bist schlau oder
das schulsystem in tschechien ist leicht
keine ahnung so was haben wir noch ach
so ich hab euch ja schon gesagt das
schlechteste zeugnis gibt es in dieser
folge was ich je bekommen habe und zwar
hat mir das jemand zugeschickt das war
nicht ihr zeug ist sondern irgendwie das
zeugnis von einem freund von ihr und
zwar geht die person auch eine
berufsschule wir haben hier insgesamt
sechs noten zb englisch sport wäre
ströme aufträge keine ahnung was der
rest ist haben uns zweimal 4 und 4 x 6
und der rest kann nicht erteilt werden
frage ich mich auch wie das gilt kann
ich hüpfe aber die person hat nur 30
fehltage
das heißt ich verstehe nicht wie man das
alles nicht beurteilen kann zur iba
kleine unterbrechung was ich jetzt noch
dazu sagen wollte auch hier wenn man 30
mal nicht da ist sage ich mal von 140
schultag wie kann dann so viel nicht
beurteilt werden naja ich denke mal du
musst in 100 kleine erster runde
einlegen
trotzdem auch hier schöne grüße dann
geht wird das zeugnis kommen noch zum
letzten part mich lesen einfach mal kurz
hier die nachricht vor
hey ich ging aufs gymnasium hatte die
wahl zwischen gymnasium achte klasse
wiederholen oder real schon der neunte
klasse habe mich für die realschule
entschieden das zeugnis endstand 60
prozent
meine lehrer und 40 prozent durch meine
baulichkeit peinlichkeit vertraulichkeit
gibt es nicht als ich glaube 20 prozent
fließt ja auch noch was anderes für mich
böse wir haben hier deutsch englisch
spanisch fünf weil hier sparen muss man
auf jeden fall sagen da ist die lehrerin
schuldner musik vier kunst hier
geschichte für erdkunde vier politik
vier werte normen 385 auch hier muss man
sagen ganz klar muss ich dass der lehrer
in die schuhe schieben also da will ich
auf jeden fall voll auf deiner seite da
kannst du absolut nix für das ist die
schuld vom lehrer 45 chemie 5 4-sieg 4
sport viel mehr so geht's dann natürlich
auch man kann auf die schuld bei anderen
suchen natürlich weiß ich es selber das
war vielleicht ein bisschen
herausgerückt also ich kann nicht voll
verstehen und ich bin da halt absolut
oft an der seite dass es nicht einen
lehrer in unserem schulsystem gibt oder
generell der objektiv bewertet also der
nicht wenigstens ein bisschen sagt okay
denn alex den mag ich oder den alex den
mochte ich nicht und dann wird halt mal
aus nach 3 plus mit zwei - oder halt mit
brei - oder so also das kenne ich
natürlich auch bei mir selber auch
schöne grüße an meine alten lehrer für
die drei - in mathe einmal hatte ich
auch eine vielen philosophie und ein
jahr später hatte ich in der einzel
lehrerin machte mich einfach nicht das
war so eine die hat gesagt ich gehe nun
mal kurz kopieren und dann war die 20
minuten weg und kamen wieder mit zum
vierten brötchen leute das waren eure
zeugnisse staffel 2 folge 2 ich hoffe
dass wieder durchgefallen wie gesagt bei
8006 gibt es nächsten freitag der
nächsten paar schaut auf instagram
vorbeischicken zeugnis zu
wir sehen uns sonntag wieder da gibt es
ein cooles video hat ein abo nicht
vergessen